there's a suit of beautiful humility in
saying I can at every single moment
contribute to making the world a better
place
and he was overwhelmed with gratitude it
was disproportionate to my tiny amount
of time and money so as I was going home
I concocted this foolhardy notion that I
was going to try and do active kindness
every single day for a stranger for a
year
utterly heartwarming completely
terrifying occasionally expensive
sometimes physically hazardous
mostly it was kind of a warm glow around
your heart and also your tummy it was
completely life transforming the biggest
lesson for me was to embrace the fact
that every single day I can do something
that thing might be just saying good
morning to someone that's how we change
the world